on est rendu là à pouvoir offrir des
lots c'était un moment attendu depuis
longtemps à lorrainville dans le
témiscamingue
le maire la préfète des gens d'affaires
de la région
tous étaient réunis pour lancer leur
projet unique au québec c'est que ça
fait un effet de réussite totale de
projet la petite municipalité a décidé
de morceler une grande terre agricole
qu'elle possédait pour la vendre en
quatre petits lots de 10 hectares elle
demande 25 mille dollars pour chaque lot
est un agriculteur moi mais je me suis
dit c'est vraiment une belle occasion de
pouvoir offrir simon sort pas comme ça
parce qu'on sait bien c'est pas facile
de pouvoir y accéder
les agricultures d'avancé les nouvelles
cultures et nouvelles façons de faire
les nouveaux modes de propriété des
terres les nouvelles façons de
travailler sa fac des coopératives ça
peut être on veut travailler autrement
les possibilités agricole ce jour là on
faisait donc visité la terre à des
jeunes intéressés par le projet il y
avait marlène de rouyn noranda quelqu'un
passionnés comme moi vous dire j'ai ma
chance on me donne ma chance en fait de
pouvoir décoller on est tous derrière je
pense que moi j'aimerais faire créer un
site agro touristique et le monde
pourrait venir visiter
il y avait aussi francis de lorrainville
et sa conjointe clara de saint-ours en
montérégie pour c'est cultiver de là à
voir une famille son instinct choix de
vie qui le biais de faire la leçon
saisissait d'encourager une relève qui
puisse pas
dès la sortie de l'école s'endetter de 2
300 mille places 4 ans est placé comme
le gros minimum c'est quand tu veux tu
acheté une propriété l'aurait ville a dû
s'y prendre à trois reprises avant que
la commission de protection du
territoire agricole finissent par
accepter son projet et encore la
commission a dit oui pour quatre petites
terres seulement alors que la
municipalité voulait tant offrir 8
rebonds 8 1 à dire on va falloir donc
enfin de demandes puis moi dans ma tête
je me dis oh je sais que c'est pas ça et
on le savait d'avancé que ce serait
peut-être pas facile c'est que la loi
sur la protection du territoire agricole
de 1978 rend difficile la séparation des
terres
en moins de cent hectares avec la loi
qu'on actuellement tout est dans
l'interprétation un peu comme dans la
dernière année que survint la majorité
des demandes qui était du morcellement
mai de 15 hectares plus longs ont été
acceptés dans les codes relève agricole
mais plus la mort seul or seulement
demandé est petit mais plus ça pose des
enjeux ses terres le seul all hall puis
souvenir pendant longtemps aux besoins
d'une famille que puissent vivre dans
votre champ agricole
la commission a aussi été échaudés par
des petits projets qui n'ont jamais vu
le jour et qui ont mené à la disparition
de terres agricoles
les gens qui achètent des terres surtout
dans les zones de villégiature très
convoité qui équivaut comme bâtir un
plan d'affaires puis à mettre sur papier
un projet agricole puis aller devant la
commission pour aller chercher un droit
de construire construire une résidence
de prestige suis pas nécessairement
mettre en oeuvre avec caroline poirier
dont la ferme se trouvent dans les
cantons de l'est est confrontée elle
aussi à la sévérité de la loi à un
kilomètre de chez elle elle a acheté
cette terre pour que son frère ils
produisent un petit élevage mais parce
que la maison qui s'y trouvait a brûlé
impossible de s'y bâtir comme ya plus de
maisons des puits en vain malgré le fait
que
on peut encore clairement à voir sur le
terrain où se trouvait la maison et on a
perdu le droit acquis de construire puis
ça va être une lutte d'aller rechercher
ce droit l'ofppt les petits producteurs
se sentent désavantagés par la
réglementation actuelle à l'heure où ils
ont pourtant la cote
la pandémie a ramené l'idée de
souveraineté alimentaire et les
abonnements aux paniers bio sont plus
populaires que jamais trente mille
ménages québécois achètent leurs
produits directement de l'agriculteur
cette année à l'est du lac memphrémagog
hugo deux fois la voix cultive des
fruits légumes pour 65 clients
il n'a que sept petites aires qui loue
avec la maison et rêvent d'avoir plus
grands la valeur des terres agricoles en
estrie région rechercher des
villégiateurs a bondi de 32% l'an
dernier c'est la hausse la plus marquée
au québec en 2019
un hectare de terre s'ils vendaient en
moyenne 8000 386 $ comparativement à
1439 dollars en abitibi témiscamingue
hugo aimerait bien et profitez en estrie
d'un projet comme celui de la ville
faute de projet ça flingue j'ose plus
d'accès pour nous qui s'amusait le
barreau a accompli sa mue avec ben les
gens de la deûle ou out ça vient porter
une solution à la réalité est que je
dirais qui tu as réalité de
l'agriculture en circuit court qui est
un modèle émergent puis qui permet de
gagner sa vie sauve inspiré beaucoup
peut-être parce qu'on va faire notre
mise en marché nous même des choses
doivent changer pour aider la relève
agricole 3 la préfète du témiscamingue
agronome de formation en protège notre
garde-manger faut jamais l'oublier
maintenant qu'on a dit ça cette fois là
il faut qu'elle soit adaptée aux régions
et aux circonstances dans lesquelles on
l'appliquent
ça limite le développement de certaines
activités agricoles à la créativité
il va au début plusieurs municipalités
surveille de près l'expérience du
témiscamingue nous a faits reprochés par
la mrc de la gaude la haute-gaspésie ces
gens le pis ils veulent savoir comment
on a fait ça que je me pince et moi
aussi
comment qu'on a fait on a bûché pour
n'était persévérer bhl pour l'instant un
seul projet a été approuvé par les
banques est déposé à la municipalité
alors que sept autres n'ont pas passé
l'étape du financement lorrainville
s'apprête donc à promouvoir